MODERATOR: Thanks for joining
us today to close out our Earth
Week with Matt Grocoff,
our special guest.
Matt and I actually
met via a tour
of his home, which
is kind of weird.
But he has America's oldest
and Michigan's first net zero
energy home.
And articles about
this home have
been featured in "USA
Today" and "The Atlantic"
and numerous other publications.
Matt is the founding principal
of THRIVE Net Zero Energy
Consulting Collaborative
and the co-founder
of Mission Zero Fest.
And he is an advocate
and thought leader
on net zero energy building
and restorative design.
So Matt, thanks for being here.
MATT GROCOFF: This is great,
because this is actually
the first talk that
I've gotten to do here.
Happy first day of spring.
It comes a little bit
later here in Michigan.
But speaking of spring and
temperature and comfort
and everything else, we don't
measure our lives in stuff,
right?
We measure our lives
in love, in happiness.
But comfort is that
tool that we use,
that zone that we
want to put ourselves
into in order to provide us that
space for love and happiness
and joy and
friendship and family,
and all those other
wonderful things
that we do measure our lives in.
But about 10,000 years
ago was the first time
it became off of the
savanna, out from, literally
from the treetops,
out of caves, places
where we were trying
to find shelter,
and started building our own
shelter from other things.
Only for about 10,000 years.
So originally, we went
around the camp fires
and we stayed warm.
They wouldn't even sleep
8 hours through the night.
They would wake up in the
middle of the night, dance
around the fire to
entertain themselves.
Now we've really tried
to capitalize ourselves
with comfort as much
as we possibly can.
So we've got ourselves now
we're entertaining ourselves
with the Harlem shake,
with Gangnam style.
We have-- originally, we're
pooping out by the tree and now
in the outhouse.
Then we brought in
the chamber pot.
But that obviously
wasn't the real way
to go, so we started
using indoor toilets,
indoor plumbing.
So we have these things
that are flushing
15 gallons of fresh
water down the drain.
But that's still
not enough comfort.
Because if you're the
toilet trained cat owner,
you've got to have one
for your cat, as well.
Now for you
[INAUDIBLE] out there,
this is the ultimate convenience
for the toilet trained
cat owner.
I'm assuming they're talking
about the cat, not the owner.
But here, if you've
got your own elephant,
you gotta have a
toilet for that, too.
It's not enough just
for the indoor animals.
We can't serve our
own coffee anymore
or cut our own hot dogs.
This one here is
my own favorite.
This is really the symbol
of the end of time,
as far as I'm concerned.
This is the proof of the over
capitalization of comfort.
I can't make this stuff up.
It's real.
You can look this up on Amazon.
There's over 2,000 reviews of
this product, the Hutzler 571B.
I think B is for banana,
but I'm not sure.
$2.48 on Amazon.
And these are real.
These are reviews.
Here's one from Miss Toledo.
She raves, "this
saved my marriage.
What can I say about the
571B that hasn't already
been said about the wheel,
penicillin or the iPhone?"
And now we're starting see
the consequences of some
of this, what I call the over
capitalization of comfort.
This is the number 350.
This is parts per
million of carbon dioxide
in our atmosphere.
This is what Bill McKibben
calls the most important number
in the world that
everybody should know.
And the reason he says that is
because James Hansen determined
that above this number, parts
per million in the atmosphere,
if we keep it above this
level for a significant period
of time, we can't sustain
the biosphere to which humans
have adapted over
these 10,000 years.
We can't sustain wildlife or
any of the living things that
adapted to this kind of climate.
But this is the
number that I think
is the most important
number, zero.
That's zero carbon pollution
going up into the atmosphere.
Because this is the number
that we can impact in our daily
lives every day.
This is the number we
can impact at home.
350 is for the scientists.
Zero carbon emissions
out of your office place,
from your automobiles,
from your homes,
completely decarbonizing
our economy down
to zero carbon going up
into the atmosphere, that's
our ultimate goal,
and that's something
that we can impact
every single day.
James Hansen gave
us that number, 350.
He says that stabilizing
atmospheric CO2 and climate
requires that CO2
emissions approach zero.
Now this is from a
scientific paper.
They didn't say
it's a suggestion,
they said it's a requirement.
It's a whole lot easier to
change the way we use energy
than it is to change
the laws of physics.
It is a physical
law, a requirement
that we have to get to
zero carbon emissions.
So this is our house.
Over here on the old
West Side in Ann Arbor.
This picture was taken
probably in about 1912.
Our house was built in 1901.
Since we've done a little
bit of work to the house,
it's gotten a lot of attention.
We were in USA Today.
It was called one of the
top greenhouses of 2010.
The Atlantic called it
sustainable perfection.
I'm getting calls from
around the country for people
to-- they call me the
zero energy master.
It sounds very dominating.
I kind of like the term.
And so I spoke at the World
Renewable Energy Forum
at Greenbuild and Living
Futures Conference next month,
and at Google.
And people are saying, what
did you do to this house?
How could you get this
112-year-old house
to net zero energy?
And it's a really simple story
that goes back to 2006, when
my wife and I were thinking
it might be a really good time
to buy a house.
And the market is going crazy.
If we buy a house
now, imagine what
it's going to be like in 2008.
[LAUGHTER]
And then we heard on the radio--
and this was a true story.
This was the catalyst.
We heard that Google was
bringing 1,000 new employees
to town.
And my wife called me.
She said, did you
just hear on NPR?
Google is coming to town.
They're bringing
1,000 employees.
We've got to buy a house now.
There's all these people
coming from California.
They don't know what
houses are worth!
So this is the house we bought.
And I'm pointing at the
computer, not at the screen.
This was the house.
This was our dream house.
We went in and buy this thing
on a July afternoon and said,
that is the house
we want to live in.
It's got everything
we could ever want.
It's got plywood front
porch, asbestos siding,
zero insulation in
the entire house,
except for a layer of
newspaper dated 1902.
We had lead paint,
which everybody wants.
We had no operable windows,
which was really fun.
Even though they
weren't operable,
and you can see some
of the little sash
locks here are missing,
you could still
stick a spatula or a screwdriver
right through that hole.
And there was plenty of
air going through it,
so we weren't worried about
suffocating in the house.
We had carpet covering
hard pine floors that
were from trees that were
harvested 112 years ago
and were probably
growing at the time
Christopher Columbus
sailed for the Americas.
Certainly worth
putting carpet over.
This was a refrigerator from
1989 inside the kitchen,
with the linoleum floors.
This was the bathroom,
with the toilet
that flushed 5
gallons every time.
So we took this much waste and
turned it into this much wast.
And my favorite part
of that bathroom,
though, is the pink towel
curtains sewed together.
This house didn't have
a shower at the time.
This was the only bath.
This was one of only two
rooms in the house that
had running water in it
when we brought in 2006.
It did have genuine
Formica tile.
A few times I made the
mistake of saying it was fake.
But no, it's real Formica.
The sink was flowing at two
or three gallons a minute,
two-and-a-half, three
gallons a minute.
This is the Mueller
Climatrol furnace from 1957.
A little white tag on there
shows the date of installation
and some inspections that
were done over the years.
This thing operated, it
was about 40% efficiency.
60% of it was just donations
to the utility company.
And for the privilege of
paying that $350 a month
to the utility company
to run this thing,
we got to sleep with two down
comforters, fully clothed
in sweat pants,
sweatshirts, socks
and a buckwheat pillow
heated up in the microwave
and shoved down at
the bottom of the bed.
Barely, barely
comfortable, at that.
So we wanted to create
a vision for what
we wanted this house to be.
Because I was a
little upset when
my mom came into
the house and she
didn't just get blown away right
away when she saw the asbestos
siding and the
carbon on the floor.
I was like, so,
what do you think?
Check out our new house.
Really upset with
my Jewish mother
and she's like-- what, nothing?
You're not going to say
a word about the house?
It'll look nice when it's done.
What do you mean?
It's beautiful.
Look at--
So we did have a vision.
Yogi Berra said that if you
don't know where you're going,
you might not get there.
And there's a gentleman in
town you might have heard of,
Ari Weinzweig, who owns
Zimmerman's Deli, a little $45
million company.
They talk a lot about vision.
And he says, vision
is not the how.
Vision is the what.
And as Sir Mix-a-Lot once said,
I like big whats and I cannot
lie.
You want the biggest what
you can possibly find.
Then we figure out how to do it.
And it was one of the Googlers,
either Larry Page or some
of the other guys who
talks about 10 times
versus the 10 percent gain.
So we wanted to go big.
We wanted to go to
this number here.
We wanted zero carbon emissions
out of a century old house.
And having no idea
that it was impossible.
But that's why we
knew it was possible.
This guy over here, from
another computer company,
he was asked, if he had
one wish, what would it be?
And he didn't say, hey,
I'd pick the next President
of the United States, or
I'd bring world peace,
or I would come up with
a vaccine for malaria.
That's what the Gates
Foundation does.
He didn't say that.
He said, instead, that he
would reduce global emissions
to zero.
Because we recognized
that if we don't
get to that goal of
zero carbon emissions,
there's no use in trying
to cure diseases or elect
the Presidents.
And there's a whole bunch
of folks jumping on board.
This small company out
of Arkansas, [INAUDIBLE]
out in California,
and the US Army, all
have these mission
zero goals of getting
to zero carbon emissions from
their company, and then some.
Ultimately, they can be
restorative companies.
So we figured if Walmart could
do it, then we could, too.
So we hired as cheap as
laborer as we possibly
could, ourselves.
And we targeted our
own mission zero,
making the house 100%
harvesting our own energy,
harvesting all of our own
water, creating zero waste.
And then not only
eliminating the harm
we're causing to the community
and to the environment
around the home, but actually
restoring the environment
around the home,
and actually seeing
what we can do to make
this a restorative home.
And we're on that
path towards it now.
Because we have the ideal
as the indicator of success.
And this the ideal.
That's my daughter, Jane.
She's four years old now.
She's the first
generation that will never
know what it's like to grow
up in a carbon polluting home.
She has no idea.
Because this is the home that
she's getting to grow up in.
This is the house in 1913.
This is Philip and
Elizabeth Gouse.
We bought the house
from Gert in 2006.
So we're really the second
family to own this house.
This is the backyard.
You can see the coal
underneath covered with soot,
and some of the grape vines they
used later during Prohibition.
And this is 7th Street.
These are the hydrangeas
that are still
on the side of our house.
This is Grizzly Peak
Brewing Company,
over at the corner of Washington
and [INAUDIBLE] Street.
It was just shortly after
this photograph was taken,
it became the
Philip Gouse Saloon.
So he would walk
out the front door
to serve beer to customers
over 100 years ago,
to the same place that we now
go to get beer and French fries.
But what makes this photograph
unique, and the reason
it was taken, was this was
the day where the Gouse
family didn't have
to burn things
themselves for their own energy.
They could flip a
light switch, and they
would get electricity
delivered to their house,
with carbon burning somewhere
else that they no longer had
to see.
First time in human history
that this had ever happened,
as soon as we started remotely
supplying electricity to homes.
So Wendell Berry says,
when going back make sense,
we move forward.
So we really want
to take a look back
at what was done
right back in the day.
Now historic
preservationists love
to say that old buildings are
the greenest buildings around.
And there's some truth to that.
They certainly did recognize
the patterns of nature.
You could look at our backyard.
Again, this is 1915.
That's Robert again
in our backyard.
And you can see
some of the things
where this house was
net zero water when
the Gouses' lived in it.
This is the cistern
cap over here.
Over to the far right, you
could see the well water,
where they'd bring in
a little fresh water
that they needed for the
house, to fill up the bath tub
or to cook with.
All the rain water
fell off of the roof
into the cistern that was used
for the gardens, the vegetable
gardens in the backyard.
So a good percentage
of their food,
up until the 1940's, about
40% of produce in America
was grown in people's yards.
Back there, there
were chicken coops.
In the 1950's, they started
making chickens illegal.
They're legal again now.
We have a few in our backyard.
Then there was a dog
house back there for Fido.
Now Fido's job was
to guard the chickens
from the foxes and
things that ran
around the Old West
Side of Ann Arbor.
The foxes are long gone.
But they did have the
composting toilet, also known
as the outhouse.
So a couple of these things
are wonderful to go back to.
Natural ventilation, harvesting
food from our own property,
capturing our water,
things like that.
And certainly,
composting toilets.
But that's probably
not the best design.
I think we could probably
do better than that.
But that these
households were perfect
is really the myth
of the noble house.
Because the Gouses' were burning
about 1,200 pounds of coal
to cook and heat with
every single month.
That's about 100
pounds of ash alone.
That's not a way we're going to
go back to heating or cooking.
Our streams and our rivers
were turned into sewers.
There were so polluted with
chemicals and everything else
from all the industrial
processes that
were going in in Ann
Arbor, heavy metal, sewage,
you name it, was going
straight into the creeks,
that in the 1930's
we decided, hey
we have the engineering
capability of just turning
these natural services
into actual sewers.
And now they're buried
in a concrete pipe.
And throughout Ann Arbor, just
about every one of us every day
walks across one
of these creeks,
without ever knowing
that it's ever existed.
One of them runs right
next door to our house.
This is the Allen Creek, as
it goes underneath Washington
Street, right by the YMCA.
It's buried under a pipe.
Before the Gouses' in the
1700's, early 1800 's,
the primary fuel for cooking
and heating was wood.
Now humans are the
only species on earth
that have ever burned
anything for our own comfort
and survival.
So wood was plentiful.
In 1799, they
wrote that Michigan
had inexhaustible hard pine
forests, inexhaustible.
No way you could
possibly use it all.
The canopy of the trees
was so thick and dense,
they said a squirrel could
hop across the canopy
from the Upper Peninsula of
Michigan all the way down
to Northern Florida without
ever touching the ground.
That's how thick the forests
of the East Coast of the United
States were.
But by 1890, this is
about how much wood
each house was burning at the
time, 15 to 20 cord of wood.
So to give you an idea, that's
4 feet wide, 16 feet high,
up to the top of these
ceilings, and the entire width
of this hall here.
Every single home
was burning that,
just to cook and heat with.
So by 1890, this was
Hermanville, Michigan.
We had exhausted 95% of
all of the forest cover
in the state of Michigan
in less than 100 years.
That was before the
population of the world
had hit 1 billion people.
So we can't go back to--
I was in a farmer's market
and somebody was selling kale.
And this guy with dreadlocks
said to me, hey, well,
we can just go back
to living in yurts.
And I'm like, well,
how are you going
to heat 130 million
yurts in the US?
That's not really a
sustainable solution either.
We can do better than that.
Lighting.
Every neighborhood,
every city had a place
where you could in and buy any
kind of liquid that burned,
really.
You had lard oil, camphor,
kerosene, whale oil.
If it was liquid and it
burned, they sold it.
And this is how
we lit our homes.
And I think it's
coming up pretty soon,
they call it Earth Hour.
Earth Hour is where
around the globe,
we want to bring awareness
to the amount of electricity
we use.
And so they have everyone
just turn off their lights.
They turn off the lights
that illuminate the Eiffel
Tower, the Empire State
Building in New York.
And everyone gets together
and has these really intimate
meals.
We all light
candles to put focus
on the attention of how
much energy we're using.
So some enterprising
young graduate student
decided, well, how much CO2
comes out of a paraffin candle?
Can we go back away from the
light bulb to the paraffin
candle to light
our way at night ?
And he figured out that
the paraffin candle
uses 10 times the amount of CO2
of an incandescent light bulb
per lumen.
So we're not going
back to that, either.
And this is what
our electric lights
look like at night from space.
Somebody said once, it looks
like the planet's on fire.
And in a way, it is.
Because we're actually digging
up these 100 millions of years
of stored solar energy and
burning them for electricity,
and setting all the particulate
matter and all that carbon
that was stored in the ground
up into the atmosphere.
And that number rises
every single day.
So here's the challenge.
We've got 130 million existing
homes in America already here.
So California has said, look,
if we're going to do this,
then all new homes from now on,
starting about the 2020 Energy
Code, they have to
be net zero energy.
And that's incredibly ambitious.
And it's necessary.
And it's a wonderful
thing they're doing.
But if you really
think about it,
if all new homes and all new
buildings are net zero energy.
They don't emit a single
bit of carbon pollution
for their entire life,
starting this afternoon,
everything new, zero emissions.
How much does that lower
our current carbon output?
And the answer is zero.
We have to do something with
the existing building stock.
So is that really possible?
Well, Amory Lovins says if it
exists, it must be possible.
So let me show you what exists.
These are the numbers
from our house.
The slide's a
little bit outdated.
This is from October,
2011 through 2012.
So this a year's worth of
energy data for our house.
On the roof of our house,
we produce 95 kilowatt hours
of solar.
We used about 7,500 kilowatts,
and we put 2,000 kilowatts back
onto the grid, that
we weren't even using.
This is what a
typical energy bill
looks like in our house, minus
the $8 a month, give or take.
Sometimes it's more than that.
Sometimes it's in the 100's,
sometimes a little bit less
than that.
So we did some math, and we
figured that over 30 years,
the life of our mortgage--
people go into the house,
they know exactly how much
taxes they're going to pay,
they know how much the
mortgage is going to be.
And I'll even give
you a chart when
you get your loan, what
are you going to spend over
30 years with all
of that interest.
But nobody says, what
am I going to spend over
30 years to run this house?
And this is the number that we
came up with, $283,000 of shift
in energy costs for
us over 30 years.
Now in fairness, that's
at 7% energy inflation.
And the coal industry say, well,
it's only going to be 4.3%.
So if we split the
difference, we're
still talking about $234,000
energy swing for us.
So net zero energy has gotten
the financial thumbs up.
But the coal industry is right.
And they'll say, well, look,
that's not fair to say 7%,
because we have no idea
what the price of energy
is going to be
like in the future.
And that's exactly the point.
There's no commodity trader
on the planet, not the best
ones out there, that will
know that in 20 minutes
at the close of the
Commodity Exchange today,
how much the raw cost of coal
or petroleum or natural gas
is going to be.
They don't know it today,
tomorrow, five days from now.
No idea.
They might get an
approximation, but they'll never
get the number right.
But any 5-year-old can
tell you exactly what
the raw cost of solar
energy or wind energy
is going to be 10,000
years from now.
The only difference
in cost is the cost
of building the power plant.
So here's how you do it.
It's a pretty simple formula.
You lose less, you
use less, and then
you produce all the
energy that you need.
And what you do is you really
try to optimize your comfort.
Because when we first moved
in, and people started
writing about our house
and the work we were doing,
everyone immediately
assumed, clearly,
they're hippies bathing
in their pasta water.
This is-- [LAUGHTER]
But as it turns out, we invite
over 1,000 people a year
to come through our house.
And we show them, we have
all the same appliances
that everybody else has.
The difference is
that they're always
the most efficient appliances,
and we control them.
So right now, our
home, I can tell you,
without even looking--
and I have a little app
for that-- exactly how
much energy we're using.
And it's probably less
than 200 watts right now,
less than a few of these
light bulbs in this room.
Our entire house is
operating off of that right
now, because nobody's home.
That little thing over
there on the corner, that
is the one old thing
that we still have.
That was my clock radio that I
bought in law school in 1992.
And just plugging that in,
doing a little math on it,
I realized that actually
uses more energy
throughout the year than the
TV set up on the upper right
corner.
So it's not about
sacrificing, saying
you can't watch Gangnam Style on
your YouTube, on your smart TV
anymore.
You got to replace the
little clock radios
and you've got to make
everything else more efficient,
and get better stuff, a
little bit more comfort,
and you control them to where
they're only using electricity
when they're delivering
you a service.
And that's the real challenge.
Lighting.
You can get the most efficient
light bulbs in the world.
But the best thing you can do
is harvest daylight for free.
It's better lighting, and
there's not much to it.
Our house is an old house,
so it was built to harvest
as much natural daylight as
possible without light bulbs.
Thermostats.
The world is changing.
A couple of guys left
Apple, the guys, in fact,
from the team who created
the iPod and the iPhone,
left Apple-- that was the time
to sell your Apple stock--
and said they don't want
to make toys anymore.
So they made that product
over on the right side.
That's the NEST.
And actually, Google is a
huge investor in the NEST.
Because they realizes
that this little product,
with an algorithm that knows
the outdoor temperature,
indoor temperature, humidity,
indoor and outdoors,
and it can optimize
exactly when you
need it to be the
temperature that you need it.
So at 7 o'clock, when your
programmable thermostat
kicks up to 70 degrees
and starts to work,
this one will have
it at 70 degrees.
Because at 4 in the morning, it
knows it's 20 degrees outside.
I need to turn on
the heat right now.
And at 7 o'clock,
it's going to be
exactly the temperature
you want it to be.
So you've optimized
your comfort,
but you've used as little
energy as possible.
Because the next day,
when it's 30 degrees,
just five degrees warmer, it
might kick on 15 minutes later,
because it knows that.
And it's going to know
exactly what time to kick on
to keep you optimally
comfortable.
So these little tiny
devices that are $200, $250,
can save huge amounts of energy.
You can imagine what
happens when you put these
into 130 million homes.
Lighting.
If there's a light bulb
on in an unoccupied room,
you're paying 100% of
the cost, but you're
getting zero benefit.
Who does that?
That's like leasing a car
that you never get to use.
So California
requires all new homes
to have occupancy sensors
in all the lights.
And every switch in
our home has a sensor.
Our lives are so much
easier, because of it.
We don't have to worry
about turning lights off
when we go out of the kitchen
carrying loads of stuff,
or going down to the basement
with a load of laundry.
They'll turn off for us.
And I don't have to
teach my 4-year-old,
go back and turn off the lights.
She knows how to
turn off the lights.
But if she doesn't, that's OK.
They're going to turn
off by themselves.
The light bulbs that
we put in, we make sure
are the most efficient
ones available.
The incandescent light bulb,
we won't talk about it anymore,
because it's infinitely more
expensive than the other two
options.
The one in the
middle is actually
what I call the 8-track
cassette of lighting,
because that thing's going to be
gone within a couple of years.
On the right side,
that's already
the most affordable
light bulb on the planet.
Because over the life
cycle of that light bulb,
although it costs
$15, the energy
you're going to
spend on it, and it's
going to last you
in a home over 20,
25 years, a single light bulb.
It ends up being the
cheapest bulb on the planet.
And you can get them at Home
Depot, Lowe's, any store
right now.
And the prices are
coming down every day.
But the biggest place
that we're losing energy
and we're really getting
screwed is in the shower.
Now I know what
you're thinking, you
shouldn't be using electricity
in the shower, anyway.
But you are.
That's all hot water in there.
So by replacing shower heads
with the most optimized
water-sense certified, really
efficient shower heads,
like they're using at
Caesar's Palace in Las Vegas,
where instead of using
2.5 gallons a minute,
you're using 1.5 gallons
a minute of water,
a family of four is now saving
16,000 gallons of hot water
just by changing a
little $40 device.
And that's all energy.
So the appliances in the house.
Right now, and that's
actually the stove we have.
Hopefully, we're going to be
changing this out very quickly,
in the next couple of weeks.
That gas stove operates
at 45% efficiency.
It's got three
pilot lights on it
that actually cost
us more energy
than cooking
throughout the year.
It's from 1969.
It's totally bad ass.
It looks really cool.
But if we replace it with this
even bad ass-er looking unit--
wait a minute.
Oh, my God.
It's gone.
No, it's still there.
This is an induction cook top.
Sadly, this one model is only
available in the UK right now.
But the induction cook top
operates at 95% efficiency
and will use electricity without
burning any carbon at all.
Then we upgrade the water tanks.
We get the most
efficient water tanks.
And now that we're
all- electric family,
Ford decided, hey,
we're going to roll out
an all-electric vehicle.
We're going to introduce
the all-American family.
They put my wife and
I in the centerfold.
And no jokes about
being a centerfold.
That's my daughter
you're talking about.
Now Ford's going to be a little
upset with the next photograph.
Because that's the Chevy Volt
that we got a few months later.
So we're using some
of that excess energy
to dump into the Volt,
where that red arrow is,
that's our electric
charging station.
And right at that moment, it's
drawing power directly off
of the solar panels on
the roof and filling up
with tanks of sunshine
right into the car.
So then we restored
all of our own windows.
We tightened them up
as much as possible.
We did apply for historic
preservation tax credits, which
meant we had to keep
the historic integrity
of the house.
It was not a gut rehab.
We only put R-13 in the walls.
And for the non-building
geeks, that's not much.
It's not even what
current code is.
But that's what could
fit into the wall.
So we just put dense packed
cellulose into the wall.
We put minimal insulation,
actually, by modern standards,
into the attic.
But we made sure the attic
was sealed really well,
so we got little air leakage.
And then, because the
house became so tight
with the new insulated
windows that we
were able to weatherstrip
the old windows
and restore the old ones,
rather than replacing them
with new materials.
The house was so
tight that we actually
went below the
standards where you're
required to have
mechanical ventilation when
the windows are closed.
So in the attic, we also have
an energy recovery ventilator.
Then in the ground
we dug three wells,
which you use for
a heat exchange
for our geothermal system.
And we have the most
efficient heating
and cooling system
on the planet.
And then, we put a bunch of
solar panels on the roof.
And we powered
nuclear power, but we
made sure we put
the nuclear power
plant 93 million miles away.
And that's the only downside,
we powered it wirelessly.
So let's go back to
some of this math
that we started with
at the beginning.
290, that's the
parts per million
in the atmosphere for 800,000
years of human history,
until about 1751, the beginning
of the Industrial Revolution.
And just about
that time, where we
start discovering coal and steam
engines and everything else,
that number starts
to tick up, starts
to go above 290
parts per million
for the first time in
over 800,000 years.
This is the number, again,
that James Hansen says
we need to stay under if we're
going to stabilize the planet.
This is the number where
we're hit yesterday,
398 parts per million carbon
dioxide in the atmosphere.
And they're concerned
that it will probably
hit 400 by May of this year.
That correlates to a 1 degree
global temperature average
Celsius since the beginning
of the Industrial Revolution.
So in 100 years, we've raised
the global temperature,
on average, about 1 degree.
It doesn't sound like much.
But to put that in perspective,
negative 1 degree Celsius
gave us the Ice Age.
So negative 1 degree
gives us the Ice Age.
And this is what a
positive 1 degree gives us.
PricewaterhouseCoopers is a
consulting firm out of the UK.
Again, not a bunch of hippies
bathing in their pasta water,
a bunch of conservative,
suited business folks
who are trying to provide
the best data they can
to their clients
about what they need
to be looking for moving forward
and what they need to expect,
and how they need to change
the way they do business.
And so the numbers they
looked at, they said,
look, if we're really going
to decarbonize and stay
below 450 parts per
million, which they say
is really the cap.
You should be at
a level below 350,
but let's stay at
least below 450,
because we're headed there, that
we need to reduce our carbon
emissions by 5.1% every single
year through the year 2050.
Now sadly, from
2010 and 2011, we
were only doing that by
about 0.7% decline each year
that we were reducing
our carbon intensity.
So they did a little study, and
they just assumed, all right,
let's say we just do 1.6%
reduction of carbon intensity
every single year, where
will we be by the year 2050?
And that's the number
they came up with.
That's my daughter Jane.
She'll be 42 in the year 2050.
Little baby Andrew, who you just
saw in the back, will be 37.
We know how to do
the right thing.
We know what is possible.
Google is doing it.
The US Army is doing it.
Even Walmart is doing it.
But we don't have a lot
of time to get there.
We've got to get this right.
The margin for
error here is slim.
Bill Bryson, in his
latest book, "At Home,"
said that the greatest
possible irony
would be that our endless quest
to fill our lives with comfort
and happiness that we created
a world that had neither.
But I really think that
it's a false choice.
It's not a choice between
comfort and happiness,
nor decarbonization.
Because the reality is that
when we do these things,
we really decide what are the
things that make us happy?
Love, friendship, family,
growing your own food,
the satisfaction of eating
a tomato off the vine,
riding your bike, being
outdoors, picnicking,
these little things, if
we really pay attention
to those things, rather
than just over consumption
and waste, those are the things
that truly make us happy,
that that's the path
that we need to be on.
Bloomberg did a
little calculation,
rising that there's enough
rooftops in America,
just on residential
homes, to power
all of our current
electricity needs.
With no further reduction,
no efficiency gains,
there's enough rooftop space
to give us all the electricity
that we need.
Now that's just electricity.
But here's a project that I'm
working on up in Travers City.
That's a Habitat for
Humanity project.
Affordable housing.
10 homes that will
be net zero energy.
So we're proving
across the country
that net zero houses
and net zero buildings
are available and possible
in every single size,
in every single climate, and
in every single price range.
This is another home here in
Ann Arbor that we're working on,
a 1949 ranch house that
will be net zero energy.
This is a building in San
Francisco, the Exploratorium
Science Museum.
They've just
restored an old pier
down by the wharf that
is 300,000 square feet
and will be net zero energy.
And then we're taking our
home even one step further
and working with students at the
University of Michigan BLUElab
to have the house certified as
part of the Living Buildings
Challenge, which will
mean that the house will
be able to harvest all
of its own water, all
of its own energy,
have zero waste,
and be restorative
to the community.
And there's a building
out in Seattle
that was just moved into.
This is the Bullet
Center office building,
over 50,000 square feet.
Again, harvest all
its own energy, water
and manage all of its own waste.
And these are buildings
that are getting
more comfortable
and restorative.
And the exciting thing
is, is that if we
can do this right
here, in Michigan,
then anybody can do it.
And if anybody can do it, that
means everybody can do it.
And that includes you.
Thanks for having me here.
[APPLAUSE]
MATT GROCOFF: Sure.
Yeah, yeah.
Just know that the longer
you take for questions,
the less time I have to
get out to Lake Michigan
and go sailing.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So a lot of the--
you talked about a [INAUDIBLE]
America.
Western European countries
maybe over the last decade,
there have been a
lot of subsidies
to do retro fits
of various types
of commercial and
residential facilities,
with solar energy
and things like that.
Is there any way of calculating
how impactful that's been,
how beneficial that's been, and
whether that model works here?
How much do you know
about how feasible it
is to make the rooftops--
MATT GROCOFF: Yeah.
Well, one of the things
they've done in Germany
is that they really
democratized the grid.
As free as we are
in this country,
we don't get to
own our own energy.
Because a century
ago, we decided
that whoever was going
to make that grid,
it was going to be
at great expense.
So just like the railroads,
we gave them monopolies.
And we've been
trying to figure out
how to manage that ever since.
So we have this really
old, outdated grid system
of electricity that's
like a Christmas tree.
If one part goes out, you lose
the entire eastern seaboard,
like we did a few years ago.
If Google wanted to use
all of this roof space
and sell the energy to
some of the other floors
or the building next door, you
wouldn't be allowed to do that.
So the utility company
owns the energy.
If you put excess
onto it, they get it.
We were lucky enough to get into
a program that was around just
for a couple of years,
where DTE was going
to buy our solar energy,
any excess that we use.
So we're benefiting
greatly financially.
And that's what's available
in Germany, where there
was a day this past summer, last
year, where Germany, over half
of the energy
during this day was
produced by renewable energy.
They have a goal to take the
entire nation to zero carbon
emissions, to be powered
completely by renewable energy,
not including nuclear,
by the year 2030.
So they want to decommission
all of their nuclear plants
by 2030.
And that's a really
ambitious goal.
Well, what's happenening is,
so companies like Google,
and the Army, and
Walmart, in Germany,
who have really bought into
this idea, all of a sudden,
there's just an extraordinary
amount of innovation profit
that's coming from it,
savings that has really
sparked all kinds
of imagination.
And people who
work for companies
that are involved in that
report just being happy.
They actually show
up to work more.
So it certainly
is possible here.
And states here that have been
the most progressive, places
like California,
New Jersey, Ohio,
have been really
aggressive with this stuff,
are getting a lot of solar.
And Germany, I forgot
what the percentage is,
but I was just reading
this yesterday.
And I believe it's-- I think
it's almost half of the energy
is actually owned by
individuals and farmers.
So that's an
extraordinary model.
And when that happens,
it can really do it.
And the other thing is
to put a price on carbon.
Because right now,
the price we're paying
doesn't get onto the
accounting sheet.
So that's all externalized.
And we have to
internalize those costs
and pay for what
that really costs.
AUDIENCE: My dad us like--
he hates solar energy,
for some reason.
And his argument is
always that whenever
he reads about these solar
cells that they cost more energy
to produce than that they
get during their lifetime.
Have you done the calculation?
MATT GROCOFF: Yeah,
it's not true.
It's not even worth answering.
It's just not true.
That's just--
honestly, I don't know
what the motives are
for that world of people
who are trying to debunk these
technologies that are proven.
There are life cycle assessments
on all of this stuff.
And certainly for
certain processes.
Some manufacturers are
more efficient than others.
There's actually a
standard now in California,
where this non-profit group is
rating solar panels from cradle
to grave, of what kind
of chemicals they use,
what their processes
are, how much energy
is used to make them, and so on.
You can use solar energy
to make solar panels.
So it's just silly.
AUDIENCE: So how do we get a
solar roof, if we want one?
MATT GROCOFF: Honestly,
it's tough in Michigan,
unless you have the
upfront capital to do it.
Over time, it will
absolutely pay itself back.
There's no question about that.
But when the costs
are unequalized,
and if you're able to make
more energy than you can use,
there's no feed-in
tariff in Michigan.
There's no real
incentives for it
to pay for itself
in the short-term.
But it is possible, in fact--
who was it I talked to earlier?
They were getting some solar
panels this week, actually.
But you can email
me and I'll give you
the names of some solar
companies right here
in the area.
So there's definitely plenty.
I don't want to discourage you.
Because there's plenty of
homes that are doing it now.
And there are ways of doing it.
You can actually be creative
and sell your renewable energy
credits in other states,
and all this other stuff.
So it's getting crazy.
And the price of solar is
dropping like computers.
It's the same curve, actually.
Whereas our was about, I
think it was $7 a watt.
It's down to $3 a watt,
since we put our panels up.
So a significant reduction.
AUDIENCE: What's the total
cost of everything you've done,
and how much of that was
subsidized by DTE programs
at the time, or--
MATT GROCOFF: Yeah.
Well, actually, the only thing
that was really subsidized
was the solar.
We have 30% federal tax credit.
We got about $19,000 back on
the solar rate from DTE upfront.
So that went directly
to the installer.
Then we get renewable energy
credits on the back end.
So the solar array itself
ended up being out of pocket,
after all those reductions,
only about $15,000.
So while our good
friends bought a car
about the same time we were
installing the solar panels,
five years later,
they have a used car
and we have free
energy for life.
And now we have a Volt, too.
But the whole rehab itself,
including the incentives
for the solar, was
$105,000, because we
did a lot of the work ourselves.
That included an
electrician, painters
to restore the outside of the
house, plumbing, new electric,
the solar, the
geothermal was a big one.
But when we put
the geothermal in,
there was no-- it wasn't even
a tax incentive for that.
But there was still
enough of a pay back
for us, because we knew we were
going to stay in the house,
that it was going to be the
most efficient and comfortable
that we could have.
And then we did get a historic
preservation tax credit,
which hopefully will
come in the mail
this next week, for about
a little over $20,000.
So that's the most significant
thing we've gotten was
we were rewarded for
restoring a historic house.
I could do a whole hour
lecture on that one,
though, because we almost
didn't get it, because of some--
AUDIENCE: Could I ask somewhat
of a follow-up question
to that?
It seems like, as you
said, the short-term costs
are a significant barrier to
something that is obviously
going to pay for itself
over the long run.
What are your thoughts on
models that you think work well.
And I know there's been a lot
of [INAUDIBLE] subsidies from
solar companies
that are no longer--
I'm trying to think about, it
seems like there could be some
sort of way that somebody who
had a lot of capital could make
this a very profitable
program to just subsidize--
MATT GROCOFF: And they are.
There are solar
leasing programs that
are very successful in
other states, where they
own the solar panels, and
they're leasing you the panel.
So that way they get
around who owns the energy.
They're not selling
you the energy,
they're selling me
the power plant.
They're not even selling
you the power plant,
they own the power
plant on your roof.
You lease it back from them.
And your payments
each month are lower
than what you would be paying
if you bought electricity
from the utility company.
So that's one model.
But all of this really has
to change dramatically.
We can't just keep
throwing money
at this company or that
company and hoping it works.
We really have to put a
price-- the reason solar is
at a disadvantage is because
the other forms of fossil fuels
are artificially
cheap, because we
don't pay for the cost of that.
You don't see in the cost of oil
spills in the Kalamazoo River
or in the Gulf of Mexico.
You don't see the cost of
the invisible carbon dioxide
and methane and everything else
that goes up to the atmosphere.
Nobody pays that.
That's just the tragedy
of the [INAUDIBLE].
So if we actually
calculate those costs
and see what they
really are, then
all of a sudden how we create
our energy really changes.
And so that's why
Germany is, really, I
think, the best model
we've got so far for it.
And they're on target.
They'll do it by 2030.
And we could all do it, if
we have the political will.
Anybody else?
All right.
Thanks, y'all.
[APPLAUSE]